bill yeah do you know how many people
will tell you they don't like oysters
but I've never had one a lot of people
yes sir and who can blame them they look
scary yes I'm empathetic to the
hypothesis that leads one there MH I
also really enjoyed the last 10 years of
my life getting people to try their
first One MH and literally seeing one
out of every two loving it and one out
of every two punching me directly in the
face cuz it was the worst thing that
ever happened to them I really do think
exploring and curiosity is a topic that
we need to talk more about and I think
it comes in all shapes and sizes maybe
you've been looking for a sign because
you're a guidance counselor but you've
always wanted to do acting in theater
and like maybe you should just go across
the street and go to the local theater
or whatever it is and ab right like
maybe this was the moment cuz you love
this guy and you're like this is the
sign I'm going to go it's the oer thesis
it's a big world attention is the number
one asset